hey guys what's going on I'm Jimmy was
in hunt game designer here on h1z1 we
just got back from e3 ran a bunch of
demos over there we focus a lot on
showing off combat vehicles and building
so today we're gonna run through that
with you guys so you can get the
opportunity to see what we were doing
over there as well as we're gonna be
able to show the boat we couldn't even
do that at e3 so we're pretty stoked to
show it off so let's jump on in alright
so we're here in game this is h1z1 for
those you guys not familiar h1z1 is a
post-apocalyptic MMO survival game it's
kind of a mouthful but it's what working
on here at SOE and as you can see the
worlds pretty big right there's there's
a lot of things that can happen here the
goal really is sandbox gameplay we want
everything to be super intuitive imagine
you're dropped in the woods with less
than what you have in your pockets right
now
you've got that you've got an axe you've
got a flashlight I'm cheating a little
bit for the purpose of showing you guys
all this I have a backpack and some
things in here that would typically take
me a couple weeks to get all the
materials for and craft so we could show
that off but yeah so all yours start off
with you have a shirt
you've got your jeans here and yeah
that's about all you got so we wanted to
be very very intuitive in the way that I
have an axe I can go on my inventory
here I can see in the crafting window to
make a campfire I need wood so I need to
chop down a tree and you know over the
years I've been trained playing video
games that if there's an axe stuck in a
stump or there's a tree and I have an
axe that I just can't chop it down
thankfully getting opportunity to work
on a game where we can actually have
some fun and be able to chop these tree
down these trees down and get all
materials you need in a pretty easy way
now I want to point out that as I chop
this thing down you'll see it here in a
bit but they're gonna fall it's gonna
make a lot of noise and as you're
looking off in the distance just imagine
that one of these trees comes falling
down right now it alerts me to a couple
things there's a player out there and
he's in the middle of trying to get
materials together so I can go out there
and I can Jack his stuff I wanted to I
could hope that maybe he has something I
need or I could just avoid them
altogether even just go out and try to
make a friend you got to be careful
those type of situations people get a
little crazy in these games and it's
definitely part of the fun but as I run
through here I am going to try to get
the materials together to show off the
bow because I'm actually going to need
it there's a zombie running up on me
right now it's a matter of fact sexually
deal with this real quick since the last
time that we showed a lot of this it's
they're actually quite a bit harder to
kill made it look a little easy there
but so our discovery system is what
starts your crafting your crafting
pathway so discovery essentially I'm
going to throw a log in here that I got
from that tree and we click discover and
it's gonna tell me that I can make wood
planks this is gonna look a little
linear at first but it now I made a wood
plank I want to take the wood plank
throw that in and it's gonna show me
that I can make wood sticks now it's
gonna open up a little bit once they
make one of these so if I when I pulled
this in you notice a lot of the stuff
greyed out now when I drag it in I can
combine that wood plank with a wood
stick which means now I have a new
recipe so I'm gonna click discover
that's gonna tell me that I can make an
animal trap animal traps is something
you throw on the ground and animals get
trapped in it you'll be able to pull
them out cook them and have food that
way and maybe some fur and stuff as we
move forward but really what I'm
focusing on right now is I want the I
want the bow and I don't know how to
make that yet so I'm going to actually
pull my shirt off here which usually
isn't gonna be an initial option you can
but you lose a lot of space I have a
backpack so we're gonna hurry on along I
got some scraps of cloth out of that by
salvaging and so now I'm gonna take the
stick I'm gonna take the cloth and then
those two together are gonna be a wooden
bow so I'm gonna craft that out and it
should Auto equip yeah there it's cool
so I am going to take these in crafting
here we go
and make a bunch of wood sticks a bunch
of wood planks and then a bunch of wood
sticks you need to discover the fact
that I can make arrows from sticks takes
a little while and now I have a bunch of
arrows so I have 15 arrows now cool so
we can move along now I want to make
sure that I got that out of the way
quick because through it throughout this
demo we do place some things in the
world but you every time we've run this
demo d3 we had no idea what to expect
we've seen very very different
situations a lot of it's due to the fact
that we have some emergent AI in our
game so as you run around you may see a
zombie other times you might see 20 or
you might see nothing at all and then
you see a deer running out and those
zombies were there last time we're not
chasing it directly at you so it's it's
a very very dynamic experience even
while we're reading demos at e3 which is
actually comes out to a lot of fun it's
not the same old thing every time I'm
gonna throw this vehicle down real quick
and I'm gonna jump on in when you find
these vehicles in the world they're
typically gonna be in different states
of disrepair so some of them are gonna
be missing a wheel but battery just
different things that allow them to run
you're gonna have to craft those items
and put them inside the inventory of the
vehicle to repair them and get them
working again they also do use gas you
can see at the bottom right hand corner
your screen there's a 95 percent right
now they're really gas heavy right now
of course we do have the right tool in
right now all the zombies are rigged up
for that you will be you will do damage
to your vehicle like as you do this
you're not just some unstoppable zombie
killing a juggernaut in a Jeep you will
want to try to hold back on doing this
all the time however I'm not gonna have
too much extended use out of this so I'm
gonna have some fun and as you move
along through a world you're gonna find
some survival camps or survivor camps
where you can kind of tell they didn't
make it through here and in these areas
you can find various things you can find
things like pre-built campfires and you
can use those if you don't already have
one kind of nice and easy and I'm gonna
try to run through here and see if we
can find anything you'll find containers
like this in the world as well as things
actually spawning on top of vehicles or
on the ground on shelves and things will
be kind of where you expect them so
you're gonna find food in shelves you're
not gonna find it kind of laying around
unless you're at a campsite and maybe
around the campfire oh my god I'm
getting destroyed
making this look a little easy right now
zombies and I think we want to continue
down this path it's pretty exciting is
that it they're pretty rough to kill
unless you shoot them directly in the
head and the bow does have drop it is a
skill based weapon at point-blank it
does take a while to draw out the bow
and actually get the arrow knocked and
everything as you can see here it's not
always the best decision just hit them
up close so you can actually still push
with the bow you can push the aam be
back you can also punch but you need to
right-click to actually pull that back
so I'm gonna jump back in my vehicle
here
she looks like I've taken some damage
I'm gonna go around this direction I'm
just a little bit ago I showed in my
inventory I have a couple things that
you normally wouldn't start with those
are foundations and these particular
foundations are our stilt foundations
they're built to be used against Hills
and a little bit easier to place and
we'll show that right up here we at e3
we're using our dew collectors as
objects that snap onto foundations and
we actually found that we would rather
have those to be something you can place
into the world and I'll show that right
here jump on out real quick gonna reach
in my inventory I'm gonna grab one of
these wood foundations the stilt
foundation now this is a high end
foundation this is gonna take you a
while to build as you could imagine you
see all these planks on it you're gonna
have to gather all those and put those
together so I'm gonna put this down
right here go up our stairs and I'm
gonna grab one of our pre can buildings
these will take a few more resources but
they're nice you just want to plop down
some storage on your property or you can
door this off and just start to flesh it
out using these buildings as well as
walls and the like
and the Duke collector that we showed
before is now placeable within the world
so you can actually find an area or you
can take over one of those campsites if
you like and just place that down there
so I am look at I'll be used for is
situations when it's raining outside or
in the mornings it'll collect some fresh
water actually think I did grab an empty
bottle a little while ago so I'm gonna
run on down to the lake down here and I
am going to put some water in it you'll
see when I do this it's gonna be dirty
water you can imagine right now going
and drinking out of your local pond or
lake it's not a good idea without
actually filtering that out boiling the
water killing all the bad stuff in it
and after the apocalypse I'm sure it's
gonna be a lot worse so I'm gonna use
this bottle and it gives me dirty water
out of this because I'm standing here in
the water and if I drink that it's gonna
do some damage to me and I'll actually
do that right now to do some damage to
me but it's also give me some hydration
so it's a little bit of a trade-off
you can filter that out with charcoal
filters filters and light boil the water
and but the new collector solves that
problem as you start crafting that sort
of thing out of a tarp and wood you'll
be able to be more self-sufficient and
not worry about the dirty one you could
collect fresh water
when it's raining actually while we're
on the topic every day we do the system
we'll pick what type of day it's gonna
be it could be a rainy day a sunny day
it could be darker when it's cloudy
outside and you can see it can vary
anything from this which is a very light
rain which actually we think you can see
here all the way up to something like
this and you can see it actually affects
the environments can affect the dynamics
of the vehicles your characters gonna
get wet he can get cold if it's too bad
outside you need to stay dry we've
actually worked out the system because
we don't want anything to be decoration
to not rain underneath trees so you'll
be safe under here throw down a campfire
and you'll be solid and dry everything
out cook your meal and all that fun
stuff so moving on forward here and a
turn turn the lights back on I want to
see what's happened we actually have
some zombies that are typically in this
area but this is where it's so
unpredictable sometimes the gear comes
running through here a wolf causes a
ruckus and they go running off so let's
see looks like there are some here so we
can hit this guy from this distance
barely and the rain also it's also not
just something that can affect your
character and just be pretty on the
ground it actually affects the how it
looks during the day as far as like a
light and everything as well so it is a
little bit harder to hit these shots
want to run up here and see if we can
find anything we had a gun up here for
the demo I'm actually glad that we don't
have anything use the bow some more and
I'm actually not gonna make it through
here I'm a horrible shot with a bow
apparently regardless fact I work on I
can't shoot worth a darn so I'm gonna
run back down to my Jeep I'm gonna go
around the corner up here and show you
guys a little bit about our dynamic
weather and our time of day stuff if
you're not familiar with that it is a
full 24 hour day cycle we do tuned how
long that lasts
speed that up and show you guys what the
day oh my god what the days and the
nights look like a zit it's a huge
difference in games like if anything
when you log in we want to make sure
that there are reasons to play at night
as well I'm actually just gonna stop
over here on this bridge and see if we
can change the hour a little bit this is
a rainy day and this is about noon on a
rainy day a really really rainy day
really Pacific Northwest you can see
there and as it starts getting a little
bit darker on in the day let's say
something like something like 10 o'clock
I'm sorry eight o'clock rather 8 o'clock
at night starts getting pretty dark and
the darkest you'll see in our game is
when it's raining outside and 3 a.m. and
it gets pretty intense you do start off
with a flashlight it will run out of
battery it has changed our game
completely if you hadn't seen anything
from us in a while we used to have a
torch we pulled the torch from the
starting equipment because frankly
everyone was on fire within 5 seconds
and so is everything else so a
flashlight I think it looks a lot cooler
it adds a different field of the game
and it's a better point light overall
but yeah that is h1z1 in a nutshell I'm
Jimmy was in Hunt game designer on the
project we look forward to giving you
guys more updates on the game as we move
forward and we hope to get you guys in
as soon as we can thank you